all right let's get into audience
questions for the week a lot of
questions
about the supreme court ruth bader
ginsburg and one of those questions i
received from
many people in the last few days is
whether roe v wade is gone if donald
trump replaces ruth bader ginsburg
um it does seem i mean listen
we're going to see what happens but uh
it seems increasingly likely
that donald trump is going to be able to
fill that vacancy on the supreme court
whether they do it before election day i
don't know
but even if joe biden were to win on
november 3rd
it does maybe even more so if joe biden
were to win on november 3rd
it does seem that um there are going to
be enough votes
from republicans in the senate remember
you need 51 republicans have 53
and only two senators have said they
would wait at least until after the
election we don't we don't know
if they would insist on waiting until
the inauguration it seems they're going
to have 51.
so one of the big questions is whether
roe v wade which is a landmark
united states ruling on abortion would
be
taken down by a six to three
court which is what it would be if
donald trump replaces ruth bader
ginsburg
with a right-wing ideologue which he
certainly would do
if given the opportunity remember that
roe v wade is a ruling
that says states can't ban abortion
altogether
now they can almost ban it so we've seen
a whole bunch of different states
um increase restrictions on
any uh medical provider that does
abortions
restrict who can get an abortion or what
needs to happen in order to get one and
sometimes these um restrictions are
challenged in court
and sometimes they go very high in in
the appeals process
and what is ultimately left to the
interpretation of the supreme court
when those appeals get to the court is
whether
they violate the spirit
of roe v wade so in practice the way you
overturn
roe v wade is by chain by creating new
precedent
a state would issue some very very
strict
ruling on abortion and it would get
appealed all the way up to the supreme
court and the supreme court might say
this is okay if that were to happen
you have effectively by precedent undone
roe v
wade and you would have many things
change in red states
and not very much would change in uh
blue states the reality is
that if roe v wade were effectively
overturned by by creating new precedent
states like massachusetts other blue
states
are not likely to see any real changes
to the availability and access to safe
abortions the red states will get
absolutely crushed and this is another
one of those ways in which i've said
before even during the trump presidency
in blue states we are insulated
in many ways from the destructive effect
of a radical
ideological reactionary presidency like
that of donald trump
so as is often the case the destruction
brought forward by republican policy and
right-wing ideology
will disproportionately hurt
right-wingers when you look at
trump trying to undo obamacare
in massachusetts we already have
something that predates obamacare called
romneycare
and it is the folks in places like
mississippi which has one of the worst
one of the worst three
health care systems in the country it is
those folks
who are disproportionately hurt by
donald trump doing things like
undoing the individual mandate on
obamacare
so that's a reality that if they're able
to do it
not a lot will change in blue states a
lot will change in red states
now does the republican party really
want
roe v wade overturned the reason i ask
is if they actually
overturn it it's conceivable
that there will be number one
significantly renewed
enthusiasm against republicans at the
state level
in order to try to legalize abortion
in a lot of these states that are likely
to overturn it and
the reality is that since roe v wade was
was issued as a decision it has been a
great
fundraising tool for republicans
republicans raise a ton of money by
saying we've got to overturn roe v wade
we need you to vote for this person and
that person and that person from
low level positions all the way up to
the president
we need you to do it so we can get the
right people in power
to overturn roe v wade if they actually
do it
they no longer have that carrot to rile
up
evangelical voters i think that there is
some merit to that and i
question whether republicans really want
to overturn it or whether they want to
keep fighting about overturning it
because it allows them to raise money
it's a question but is roe v wade in
danger
with a six to three court particularly
if donald trump gets reelected
and particularly if we maintain a
republican senate yes
it is in danger what it will mean in
massachusetts is a different question